putting a mouse in a maze can tell you a
lot researchers have been using puzzles
like these for over a century to study
how rodents brains help them get around
their environments but what if you want
to study the human brain putting humans
in a giant maze is pretty impractical
but neuroscientists have been working on
replicating rodent studies in humans and
they do it using virtual reality there's
a whiteboard right there and then
there's a door oh no I got a sad face
I failed so is virtual reality the
future of neuro scientific research to
find out I'm going to be navigating my
way to some virtual labs trying out some
VR technology and experiencing the world
of a virtual lab rat the first location
on my journey is here at the Norwegian
University of Science and Technology
when neuroscientists have been trying to
understand the strategies people use to
find their way around Tobias never
off-roader
has promised to show me one of their
virtual mazes well it's nice to meet you
that's great here we researched a
spatial navigational memory and we used
this omnidirectional treadmill that
monitors play want to give it a go yeah
sure so what you're gonna do memory
tasks there will be objects on the
ground so try to remember where they are
okay okay I'll be honest it's not what I
imagined a maze would look like no I did
feel a little like a lab rat and this is
actually the kind of puzzled rats are
given in modern tests a lot of the
recent work is done in circular or
square environments basically just the
boss okay now you asked to put back
remember oh that face I failed so what
it told you about on the exact opposite
side so it was not random what you did
why am i doing this in in VR like a
computer gaming and not just in the real
world it's always the same time
afternoon that's what this balls I can
make these objects disappear and appear
magically on the spot so we have a high
control over the type of things you
experiencing and we can have a large
number of people go through this exact
experience is much better smiley I've
got a medium face it's actually pretty
close my successes and rather more
frequent failures helped to buy a see
how I'm approaching the task but if
we're going to see what's going on
inside my brain we need a very different
piece of kit an MRI scanner this time I
can't move at all and the virtual maze
appears on a small screen
it's obviously not as realistic and
experience but now Tobias can see which
brain areas are lighting up doing this
experiment on different people and
comparing the results can reveal
differences in which brain areas they're
using so what are then the disadvantages
of the fact that it is VR and not a real
experience one of the big disadvantages
is that you only have vision you only
see the world and in the case of the
scanner your body and head are fixed so
that's very different from everyday life
virtual reality gives you complete
control over an environment and that's a
big attraction for researchers but they
also want those environments to be as
realistic as possible the closer to
reality the virtual world is the closer
the brains behavior will be terror
attacks in the real world
I found the omnidirectional treadmill
pretty immersive but it's impossible to
use at the same time as an MRI scanner
but there is a way around this problem a
way to pay inside brains while they're
exploring virtual worlds virtual reality
rooms
what are we gonna be doing so this is
Corey he has graciously volunteered her
time to do the study and she's very
special in that she has a system
implanted in her brain that can actually
record brain activity it's actually for
epilepsy for preventing seizures but we
can actually look at the activity look
at the brain data in a part of the brain
called the hippocampus which is very
important for memory and spatial
navigation having to remember we're a
trigger point one two three and four
were and then they have me go to like
five red it's like Yahtzee or what's
that thing where you twist her like
twist her just like in Tobias's
experiment Cory finds herself in a very
simple type of maze there's like a
supply closet right there then there's a
door and the cylinder that I'm supposed
to go into is right here so this is the
first time we can record deep brain
signals while somebody's actually moving
around we've never been able to do that
in a human being before so she can learn
things she can interact with people she
can do all sorts of things so this is
the beginning of many many studies to
come to look at what's happening in the
brain at exact moments of naturalistic
behaviors and real-life activities there
aren't many participants like Cory
available for studies and it's possible
that the brains of people with epilepsy
might have differences from an average
brain but there is still an advantage to
being able to measure brain signals
during the immersive simulation we are
seeing that there are properties of
these brain waves that do react
differently depending on the what the
person is doing so it's really important
then that the participants are actually
doing something they are actually
walking at a particular speed or
whatever so you can see what's happening
during that yeah it's important that
they're doing something and that we can
actually
monitor what they're doing very
precisely and that's why we have all
this this room and the setup and
complicated equipment so the VR you can
control it carefully so you know for a
scientist all your variables controlled
which is great but is there not a
disadvantage in that it still sort of
clearly artificial world is that a
problem I mean definitely we want to be
really a replica of the real world and I
think the VR field is the technology
itself is still evolving but you know
yes it's it's it's not quite the real
world right it's still a virtual
rendition of the real world but is
virtual reality realistic enough for our
brains to act like they do in the real
world
to find the answer researchers need to
compare real and virtual worlds but
there hasn't been much research on this
yet at least not in humans another lab
around the corner from non-theist has
been asking this question though they
use more conventional lab rats in there
and look at what's going on
so that's Sina that's alright so we are
going to put the rat in this virtual
reality where he has to figure out where
he is
using only vision so it looks like this
rat is on a giant she's on a giant
floating ball that every step he takes
the world changes accordingly so it's
like a bigger than IMAX he's totally
surrounded by that in every direction
all the way up to his feet so he sees
his own shadow and you're going to do
that and you can see how compelling it
looks for yourself alright okay great oh
so we're gonna pretend that your hand is
the rat I'm walking and I can see it
okay I'm getting close coming yeah
things are coming towards you Gardevoir
and when you've got a rat and you're
doing the experiment you're actually
recording the brain signals that's
exactly right
you know hurry up because if you don't
find it quickly enough it will be time
out oh no because you know right find
this reward in about three seconds you
did it
virtual reality allows the brain
to make a map using only vision yeah now
we are going to see how the brain makes
map in the real world where all the
senses are telling you where you are not
just vision all right a second this
looks familiar so this is the real-world
version of the virtual maze have the
same patterns and the rat has to now run
around in this maze and we can measure
the activity of the same neurons as in
the real virtual world so we can compare
now whether the neurons the map of the
space that neurons made in the real
world looks exactly the same as virtual
reality or not during these experiments
electrodes in the rats brains measure
the activity in a brain area called the
hippocampus previous work has suggested
that the neurons in the hippocampus
create a kind of mental map that
represents the spaces the rats are
exploring so in the experiment that
we've just seen you've gone to a lot of
trouble to make sure that the virtual
world and the real world are identical
so there's no external sound there's no
air moving and it looks exactly the same
so you would expect then the brain
recordings that you get from the rats in
those two places should be the same
right that's exactly what we expected
but what we found could not be more
different
first thing we noticed is that 60% of
the hippocampus shut down in virtual
reality and when we saw this the first
time that happened with a wait a minute
maybe or something went wrong with his
brain
maybe the electrodes got damaged so we
put him back in the real world nope the
neurons are still there that's all right
what about the remaining 40% of neurons
are there maps as good as the real world
or better
once again major surprise that the maps
of these neurons were completely
corrupted so even though the mouse
looked like it it was doing exactly the
same thing and it knows where it's going
somehow the brain just wasn't reacting
in the same way why would that be we
think that what happens in virtual
reality is that different senses are not
saying
same sing to the rap when the rat takes
one step in virtual world his feet are
telling him yep I'm putting a lot of
effort I'm moving but his guts are
telling no you're not going anywhere
his head is telling him not I don't feel
any wind coming in and does this apply
to human VR studies as well when you
have people walking around with
electrodes in their head or even just on
on a on a treadmill there is merit to
simplify the real world and say I'm
going to forget about these four things
in the real world and I'm going to focus
only on vision if on the other hand our
goal is to say I want to understand how
the hippocampus works in natural
conditions then the only thing to do is
the natural condition so in my opinion
we need to do not just the real world
not just virtual reality but both in the
same subjects as virtual reality
research continues to grow the question
of accuracy is only going to get more
important it's not yet clear whether
humans show the same unusual brain
patterns in VR as - rats do or how
significant that might be for different
research questions and we don't know how
immersive a computer simulation has to
be before our brains will react
naturally but the researchers I spoke to
on my journey all agreed that despite
ongoing questions VR technology isn't
going anywhere really difficult together
that's amazing
you
[Music]